what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I have the incredible team
behind the movie radical
I had the pleasure of watching your
movie in the privacy of my own home and
I fell in love with it and it was one of
the greatest joys for Sundance to start
and then to be able to see the reaction
from many many people here that I had
and I just I knew I knew this movie was
going to have that effect here
congratulations thank you thank you so
I'm very excited about it a lot of
people here are very excited about it
our audience who isn't in Park City
right now might not know what radical is
just yet so for anyone here who wants to
do this honor can you give us a brief
description of radical
everybody's looking at me
uh well description of the story it's
it's a story about uh
a teacher in uh Matamoros Mexico which
is a Border Town uh along the border
with Texas
um who uh 10 years ago about 12 years
ago
um was you know became a teacher because
the only thing he wanted to do in his
life was
uh Inspire kids as he had been inspired
you know we all have that teacher that
affected us and in some cases they make
you become teachers
um and he was a miserable failure
nothing was working he had a nervous
breakdown
um and he decided to change his approach
uh desperately rather by the seat of his
pants found a TED Talk uh on a you know
YouTube video uh which was basically
that kids will want to learn about what
they or kids will learn about what they
want to learn about uh and and
essentially to to put the kids in charge
of their own education which means see
your own authority uh and sort of give
into the chaos of that
um and so it's a story of of
this one kind of incredible magical year
where he where he did this and starting
with one of the lowest performing
classrooms in the country what he did in
one year is it's it's truly unbelievable
and it's a true story and it's a true
story and
um yeah
incredible incredible and hugely
inspiring then I wanted to come your way
now is reading the production notes and
I believe someone had referred to this
project as a second chance for for Chris
so you find the article you option it
and Chris had been off the grid for a
little bit what was it at that point
that made you say you know even though
he wasn't fully involved in the industry
at that time I got to go back to my
friend with this particular piece of
material
um yeah I think he describes as a second
chance I described it as a great
opportunity for us because uh I had
produced his first movie and I knew what
he was capable of and we had been
talking for years for trying to find the
right project but I think this was a pro
this was a movie that both wanted to be
uh kind of honor the genre of the
teacher movie subvert it and also
create a tension between that and a very
naturalistic uh story and that's what he
did with butter nuestro or Sangre De Mi
Sangre and I knew he was capable of it
and he'd been living in Guatemala and he
had been dealing with the education
system there there were so many reasons
but he was just the the only choice for
both me and Ohio
I want to go to you now Chris and throw
some compliments back Benz wakes another
thing I had read you said that Ben is
the most committed and courageous
producer you've ever known what was the
very first point that you realized that
he had those qualities and you had to
keep working with him oh in film school
that's why I bring it up Ben and I were
classmates at uh the Columbia graduate
film division which is you know Columbia
film school where it turns out you went
uh so
um uh no I mean in the 66 incoming
student class that we had when you come
in you choose a nominal concentration we
had one on day one we had one person who
on day one chose to be producing
concentrate and it was Ben
and and you know we had a world-class
oscar-winning producing faculty and it
was like uh hey buddy you're gonna come
under the wing uh and they they they
teach an approach to producing which on
its face might seem like it's seating
Authority but um I think Ben is an
exemplary example of of uh it's it's
actually an exercise encourage and uh
and that is to say I think the work is
to find the person with the vision uh
and that can be a process that can be
conversation it certainly has always
been with us when a project is in
development but then you support the
hell out of the vision and
um and that's what Ben does and it's a
lot of um incremental like he he knows
where he ultimately wants to get but he
gets me there very gently so it's a
process but it's it's a joyous
collaboration it really is and it always
has been such a perfect pairing of
qualities for a producer to have there
not to harp on the stepping away thing
for a bit but I I did want to ask you
another question about that because in
this industry it can be very scary to
prioritize self and to leave for a
little bit and not be worried that you
won't be able to have a path to come
back so for anyone else out there who
might be going through that kind of
experience and afraid to care for
themselves but then also realize the
fact that that door doesn't completely
close behind you what would you say to
them yeah I mean I think that's a great
question and it I think also applies to
filmmakers that are here right now at
Sundance especially with their first
movie they're short whatever it may be
you know I did all the wrong things
after winning the grand jury prize
um which is to say that that I think
that the key thing is you know the
industry is brutal it can be unforgiving
but the but on some level it's
irrelevant
um and that that what we have to do as
filmmakers is to to do us do you you
know what what is it called you to this
what is that got you there and it's very
easy and there are there are there are
very real Logistics like you need to
feed your family which certainly was
something that I experienced but but
gradually it took me further and further
off track and I had to have a kind of
self Reckoning moment which is like wait
a minute I need to I need to time out
it's very similar to the circular I need
to do this differently I need to I need
to take another approach and for me that
approach was I need to just remove
myself I need to I moved to Guatemala
where I've been living now for eight
years it's Paradise I love it but it was
a place in a space where I could come
back find myself again incubate my own
things and it was it was literally in
that context that these guys called me
with this project and it was just like
uh I mean it was incredible opportunity
to come back on some level it was Kismet
but but for me to be honest because I
had worked with both of these guys with
Sangre me Sangre
it was like getting the band back
together I just before I even read the
article which was amazing it was like oh
I I hope it's good because I want to
work with these guys again
all right you give me a good transition
Josh I'm coming your way for the article
now so this isn't your first experience
seeing one of your articles adapted into
a feature film so what's something about
your experience with spare parts that
you liked and you wanted to maintain
when bringing your uh your article to
screen with radical but then also what's
something about the story of radical
that demanded a different approach for
you well I think the the thing that is
probably two words it's Ben O'Dell
and it's getting a lot he's coming back
to bed I like it this is the Ben O'Dell
show uh so I had written a book uh and
an article in in the Arts about a
a team of teenagers who built a robot
and that got turned into a movie by Ben
called spare parts uh and so yeah and it
was a it was a really fun process that's
where we met that was 20 the process
probably started in 2013 and film came
out in 2015. and I had just gone to
matamotos to report on this story of
Sergio
and it frankly it didn't necessarily it
didn't seem like a movie to me right off
the bat
um I was personally interested in it I'm
interested in education my wife is an
educator this is what we talk about all
the time in our family but Ben and I
were spending a lot of time together on
spare parts and so I was telling him
about this story in Matamoros about this
teacher who had reinvented the way he
taught in a in a classroom that nobody
was really paying attention to and Ben
was like I think there may be something
there and it you know it's not an
obvious Hollywood movie
um I don't know has anybody made a a big
movie big Hollywood movie in Matamoras
before
I don't think so I think this could be
the first so I and I when Ben expressed
interest I was so excited like this is a
an educator who is really provocative
who's doing great things and deserves
the attention
I could not agree more
you're up now oh my God you're so good
in this you're so good in this movie so
in a movie we only get to see a slice of
someone's life and hopefully we can we
could feel their history through the
prep work you had done so what is
something that you learned about Sergio
who you know something that maybe we
don't necessarily see in a frame or hear
about via dialogue but it was something
that you held tied to and we could feel
informing our performance to make his
world and his experience feel whole
well uh I feel I feel related to said
huon and to this story because uh when
we were preparing this uh this movie
um my background is has been always as a
comedian I've been doing comedy my
entire lives
and
um
when
Ben brought this project to me uh it was
a little bit scary
and uh I knew that I have to to change
my method and when I was talking to to
Chris about the character I wanted to
change my my face my hair everything
right because I won and he was like no
no it has to be you naked and I was like
um but I I I I I well
um were there anything in my face or my
hair but uh because I've been doing
comedy I wanted to really change and it
was no change from your inside
so what I did was a an internal work
trying to find Sergio inside of me so it
was it was very very complicated to me
probably this is the most challenging
um movie that I've done because it's
completely out of my comfort zone
I think you found a new comfort zone
yeah
within this genre in style and tone
Jennifer and Mia you're up first off a
first feature is a big deal so
congratulations
going into your very first film what
part of the filmmaking process
intimidated you the most and where did
you find the confidence to overcome
those nerves
Como
is
situation
foreign
Paloma
aniko
I'm gonna I'm gonna not necessarily
remember all of that
um uh but it was a the thing that gave
me the most the most fear was a scene uh
that she had to do with Nico that was
after this uh this fight this this uh
moment where where she has to go and
kind of get him back
um and um it went to a lot of difficult
places that that related to her own life
um and she had to
um
sort of tap into something
Mr
coaches
so with our acting coach we we had an
acting coach who was basically almost
like a Zen meditator which was to
constantly just keep them present keep
them I mean they had no technique really
yet uh but with that that coach keeping
myself present and to remind me that
this was just acting that this wasn't
real that that basically don't get
yourself lost in it that it was going to
go away that you could get through it
that's that's how she got through it is
e
yeah right okay so so the the scene that
I that I found most challenging and most
difficult was the scene uh where she
discusses abortion uh because there was
a it's a loaded uh difficult topic uh
for her and um the way that she really
got through it was to actually talk to
it her family a lot about it uh do a lot
of work there were a lot of a lot of
conversations but that process um gave
her the confidence to learning about
this yeah
research doing research I'm sorry yeah
and she did a bunch of research and got
into the subject two words something
else in this movie I can't get over it
the entire ensemble here is something
else honey I'll throw this to you so you
have a filmography that is wildly
impressive and down to the floor so much
experience but working with a young
Ensemble like this they're making their
first features here is there anything
that you saw these young actors do that
you wish that you could go back and tell
you when you were first starting out
like you you could try that too if you
wanted
well I probably uh the fact that they
are not and I I was born in in a family
that was in in the show business my mom
was like the soap opera Queen in Mexico
uh so I was very aware of Show Business
um this is their their first job for
them so uh I found that the fact that
they were not trained it was good for us
because they were natural and they were
not conscious really of the cameras many
I mean after
three hours of being inside the
classroom and being shooting with the
cameras around they forgot that we were
shooting
and when I was a kid I was always aware
of the camera I was too worried about
that so I would have loved to be like
that to be not aware that I was that I
had a camera in front of me the solution
is three cameras okay now you don't know
which one is which one is which and
therefore you're always you're lost I
like that tactic there Chris can you
speak a little bit to how this true
story influenced you know the script
structure your approach to directing
your actors on set literally every
element of this production yeah well I
mean I think the thing about the true
story is that the the the the actual
thing that happened the actual result is
literally it was like too good to be
true and so when Ben sent me the project
the first thing I said is
um hey we gotta play this the other way
uh we got to play against it maybe it's
not even in the movie
um what actually happens maybe it's not
part of the what we're filming maybe
that's that comes after
um but but it it sort of mandated I
thought
um first of all a very naturalistic
realistic kind of kind of approach but
but the other piece was like What if we
tell this story truly from the
perspective of the kids here we have the
biggest movie star in the history of
Mexico
um would it be radical if uh in fact we
enter the movie through their world and
we see it through their eyes and
um and so filmically the big joke on set
was that our you know our our visual
reference for the movie was Charlie
Brown you know where all the parents all
the adults are cut off at the head
um
um so that like the kids this is you
know we're down in this little world and
there's this world of adults and all
this hectic stuff going on above them
and and that and to a degree it even
antagonizes us as as the audience that
creates this kind of numbness this kind
of noise which I hoped would capture to
some degree the reality that these kids
face there and where something like an
education is almost an afterthought and
it takes this light and by the way I
knew when I got the project too I was
writing it for that there was going to
be this incredible light there was going
to to be this fun this humor this joy
that Ohio just is literally in the
embodiment of coming into that space so
I had those elements and it was just to
me it was just a super fun
uh Prospect in writing it was a joy
because I knew who I was writing it for
you know I just want to say that this is
the first time in the history of
Sundance that someone has used Charlie
Brown as a reference for their movie
works very very
using radical and your answer there is
making me think of this because I'm
always curious about coming up with film
titles it might seem like a little thing
but it winds up being incredibly
important why that particular word is it
because it was in the title of the
article is there is there any other word
you consider there's a huge disagreement
about this amongst us
um no which is on the script my working
title was always Untitled quote radical
project and that that word radical was a
reference to the subtitle uh on the uh
of the article on the cover of Wired
Magazine a radical way of unleashing
Genius
um and and then one day Ben was just
like you know I mean we were so the
shorthand for the movie was always
radical and then one day uh that's
actually so see that's why that's why
we're arguing about no yeah we just
found an email where I said the title is
radical I think it's a great title way
before well I guess I wasn't in the memo
what does he like to say I take things
slowly I didn't want to hit him with the
title too early no I was like wait is
that the title he's like yeah of course
that's the title I'm obsessed a with
with one words Idols because I think
graphically they're so much better B is
a word that works in English and Spanish
obviously so that's powerful and C the
idea that the contrast between a teacher
teaching children and the word radical
and the irony of that that you have to
be radical to break through a broken
education system that was always my
obsession but I also knew there would be
a lot of pushback so I was very slow and
and is an ironic title possibly like is
it really so radical right exactly you
know that's the thing I was just having
that conversation about one word titles
with someone I think it's true it's like
it's like Punchy it makes its point and
it makes it Unforgettable too so I
always love I feel like we don't tell
each other good job in this industry
nearly enough and don't celebrate how
proud We Are of our own work nearly
enough too so anyone can jump in on this
is there anything you saw someone either
in front of the the camera or behind the
lens do on this production that made you
go like damn you went above and beyond
on with your work and I am proud of you
for that I mean I'll just start with uh
Chris ohanio these girls I I think
everybody brought their a game to this
and it starts I I always feel like it
starts with the director and honestly
there's not a there's not an image in
this movie a choice of color anything
that wasn't really thoroughly thought
through by Chris and I think when you
set that tone and you set that bar that
high everybody else Rises the occasion
Ohio always rides the occasion but all
these kids they felt how much like a
good teacher who cares will get kids to
learn because they care about what
they're doing when a director is so
thorough and passionate it just sets a
bar and that's why Chris is Chris and
that's why we're all here
I love an interview where we're just
like throwing compliments around
everyone well we love each other no I
mean at the end of the day you know it's
also you make a movie about family which
this is a teacher is a metaphor for a
parent on some level and the idea of
finding family creating family you have
to do that in the movie too if you want
it to come off on screen it's a process
but I mean to me it's the kids I never
you know I thought we were gonna have to
shoot around them I thought the editing
was going to be a process where we maybe
would find one out of seven Clips where
someone was not goofing off in the
background or whatever and that was not
at all the case they were so zoned in
all the time and again they were working
with I mean these girls cried when they
when we told them who they were working
with that's how that's how insane it is
I'm gonna give you my last question here
because I read this a couple times in
the Press no it's just about and like I
get this feeling in interviews that I've
watched that you've done you're so
incredibly humble give me whether it's
in this movie or anything you've done
something you've done in a movie that
made even you go like damn I'm proud
proud of myself that I pulled that off
well
um it happened to me with this movie
when I was watching
um I saw a previous cut but not this
that it was the last the final cut so
when I was watching the the movie and uh
probably this is the first time I like
what I did especially because I'm always
criticizing myself so bad
and uh every movie that I do I I don't
like myself I I don't feel I'm funny
enough
but right now because it's a different
genre I I liked it I think that's the
first time I I I say I work with him all
the time we do a lot of stuff together
that's a miracle he never says so even
he admit it out loud as a miracle and
yeah yeah so I love it you should be
proud of this movie and literally
everything I've seen you and my God and
all of you huge huge congratulations on
radical a seriously special film that I
can't wait for the whole world to get to
see Amen to everybody out there keep an
eye out for radical and stay tuned we'll
have more Sundance 2023 interviews for
you very soon
thank you congratulations thank you so
much